[Music]
welcome to year in review the show where
we break down a year to bring you some
of the most notable moments in tv and
film month by month the 80s were a
decade when hollywood thrived a bunch of
now classic sitcoms were just starting
up albiebach became arnold
schwarzenegger's signature catchphrase
and eddie murphy was in the year's
highest grossing film and the year made
such an impact on hollywood that it
continues to sneak itself into modern
day films and series alike just think
american horror story 1984 summer of 84
stranger things 2 and of course patty
jenkins wonder woman 1984 just to name a
few so what was it about this year that
cemented its place not only in hollywood
but as a prominent year in pop culture
history let's take a trip down memory
lane to find out here's your year in
review 1984 edition
in a year that was full of blockbuster
hits the year didn't really get going
until february with the release of
footloose
[Music]
kevin bacon taught us the power of dance
in this film that takes place in a
midwestern town where dancing and rock
music are illegal
footloose tells the story of wren
mccormack a teenager raised in chicago
that moved with his mother to the small
town of beaumont to live with his aunt
and uncle soon after arriving wren who's
a music fan learns that the city council
has banned dancing and rock music in
their town ultimately after falling for
the local reverend's daughter and making
friends with his senior classmates ren
goes before the city council and fights
to repeal the dancing rock music law he
does so with the hopes that his class
can enjoy a prom
that's it man
what
a dance
what
a dance we could have a dance
you know a dance you know dance you know
what i mean
you're gonna get
the plot of the film is loosely based on
real-life events that occurred in the
small town of elmore city oklahoma
dancing was banned for almost 100 years
in this city the ban was finally lifted
in 1980 when the graduating class made
history by getting permission to dance
at the prom
from the oldest of times
people danced for a number of reasons
they danced in prayer
or so that their crops would be
plentiful
or so their hunt would be good
and they danced to stay
physically fit
and show their community spirit
and they danced
to celebrate
critics say there's not much dancing but
what's there is great the rest of the
time footloose is a nice hunk of trashy
teenage cheese but with an audience
score of 71
audiences don't seem to agree with
critics on this one
we're very lucky in the sense that we've
got two visionaries in the band you know
david and nigel are both like uh
like poets you know like shelley or
byron people like that the two totally
distinct types of visionaries it's like
fire and ice basically you see i feel my
rose in the band is to be kind of in the
middle of that kind of like lukewarm
water the mockumentary co-written and
directed by rob reiner followed a
filmmaker making a documentary about a
once famous now almost forgotten british
heavy metal band but this cult comedy
transitioned into a cultural institution
in 2002 when the library of congress
selected the film to be preserved in the
united states national film registry as
a culturally historically or
aesthetically significant film i'm gonna
release the album
because they have decided that the cover
is
sexist
well so what
what's wrong with being sexy i mean
there's no sexual assault
critics say smartly directed brilliantly
acted and packed with endlessly quotable
moments this is spinal tap is an
all-time comedy classic this is a top to
you know what we use on stage but it's
very very special because if you can see
yeah the numbers all go to
11. look right across the board
11 11 and mostly 11 and amps go up to
10. exactly does that mean it's louder
is that any louder well it's one louder
isn't it
do i look any older today
oh no no i wouldn't say so do you think
so no oh i hope it isn't cold tomorrow
you know jenny she'll refuse to happen
cold over
i'm gonna go set myself up in mike's
room so i'll see you guys later okay
sweetheart
grandpa and i are looking forward to a
nice long long visit with
you we certainly are really ready for it
i'll see you a little later darling
we've got a lot
i swear to god this has got to be a joke
grandparents for getting a birthday
16 candles marked the directorial debut
of john hughes though he had already
made a name for himself writing classics
like national lampoon's vacation and mr
mom the film follows suburban teenager
samantha played by molly ringwald who
suffers silently as her family forgets
her birthday on the eve of her sister's
wedding
oh i'm sorry you'll have to buy lunch
today i didn't have time to fix your
carrots yeah she's only eating carrots
to increase the size of her breasts
mr you had better shape up or you will
miss your sister's wedding
promise
now don't give me that pouty look of
yours
you can eat your carrots when you get
home
that's it you don't have anything else
to say to me today
what would you like me to say sam
come on now honey you're gonna miss the
bus
have a good day
i can't believe this
they forgot my birthday hughes cemented
his filmmaker status with this film and
went on to direct a number of other
classics like the breakfast club ferris
bueller's day off and planes trains and
automobiles critics say significantly
more mature than the teen raunch
comedies that define the era 16 candles
is shot with compassion and clear
respect for its characters and their
hang-ups
i load the bus
there has to be more dignified mode of
transportation
hope you get a car for your birthday and
a license let's not hold our breath
[Applause]
score a direct hit
[Music]
second thought
one could argue that the films released
in summer of 1984 really helped define
the decade while that's up for debate
one thing is certain from indiana jones
to ghostbusters that summer gave us the
origins for some iconic modern day
franchises june 8th 1984 was a huge
weekend for movie lovers ghostbusters
and gremlins both premiered on that day
to huge box office results
thanks dad you're gonna like this
what is it a bird cage no no no no don't
shake it we're gonna have to open it now
won't wait till christmas
it's a puppy isn't it
in gremlins a gadget salesman is looking
for a special gift for his son and finds
one at a store in chinatown the
shopkeeper is reluctant to sell him the
mogwai but sells it to him with the
warning to never expose him to bright
light water or to feed him after
midnight all of this happens and the
result is a gang of gremlins that decide
to tear up the town on christmas eve
and gremlin's secret of the mogwai is
hitting hbo max this year the animated
fantasy television series will consist
of 10 episodes and serve as a prequel to
the 1984 film and its 1990 sequel the
new batch critics say whether you choose
to see it as a statement on consumer
culture or simply a special effects
heavy popcorn flick gremlins is a minor
we classic we saw we kicked its ass did
you see it what is it we got it
is it will there be any more of them
sir what you had there it was what we
refer to as a focused non-terminal
repeating phantasm or a class 5 full
roaming vapor real nasty one too
ghostbusters was the second highest
grossing film of the year making over
295 million dollars the certified fresh
film was also nominated for two academy
awards best visual effects and best
music and while it didn't take home the
trophies it has left a lasting legacy on
hollywood creating its own franchise
spawning four films three television
series and its own comic book series
it's right here ray it's looking at me
he's an ugly little spud isn't he i
think he can hear you right don't move
[Music]
critics say an infectiously fun blend of
special effects and comedy with bill
murray's hilarious deadpan performance
leading a cast of great comic turns
and speaking of franchises we can't
forget to mention the karate kid which
first hit theaters back on june 22 1984
must make sacred fact
i promise teach karate
that to my part
you promise learn
i say you do
no question
that your part
dear
still
this beloved film was the beginning of
the far-reaching karate kid franchise
which now has three sequels a 2010
reboot and a netflix sequel series cobra
kai which picks up where the original
movies left off
finish him
fight
[Music]
the new champion
[Music]
[Applause]
critics say utterly predictable and holy
of its time but warm sincere and
difficult to resist due in large part to
patmarita and ralph macchio's relaxed
chemistry
[Music]
prince
in his first motion picture
[Music]
another thing that was big in 1984 music
michael jackson's thriller was at the
top of the music charts bruce
springsteen released born in the usa and
everyone was still dancing to the
footloose soundtrack after prince's rock
drama film purple rain was released on
july 27 1984 the album by the same name
jumped to number one on the billboard
top 200 list and stayed there for 24
consecutive weeks and to no one's
surprise the film went on to take home
the oscar for best music
he risked too much for the one thing
that meant everything
his music
critics say purple rain makes for
undeniably uneven cinema but it's held
together by its star's singular charisma
not to mention a slew of classic songs
[Music]
another thing that was a big deal in
1984 fall tv
september 1984 welcomed some
groundbreaking new tv shows to the mix
including miami vice who's the boss and
punky brewster how long will it take you
to get ready
i'm always ready
[Music]
debuting on september 16 1984 miami vice
was one of the highest rated television
shows of the decade the show was a hip
drama about a pair of high style
detectives that added neon and attitude
to the genre and drew huge numbers a
prime example of 80s flash it influenced
fashion music and other tv series and
was the show du jour for pop stars and
celebs seeking guest shots what is this
come to you a model leads us to certain
factions look we're not here to play 20
questions we're here for a motto release
him he's there end of a conduit through
him certain factions in central and
south america supplied without
embarrassing us
supplied
guys like dupas
yeah
give me the key
lieutenant
the lieutenant's been here before he
knows how it goes
i try to tell you fellas
i got the juice
it also often brilliantly mixed rock
music colors and action with strong
acting especially from emmy winner
edward james almost and an underrated
don johnson make no mistake vice left
its mark as an ultra slick period piece
[Music]
well you just gotta learn to go with the
heat rico
it's just like life
just gotta keep telling yourself
no matter how hot it gets
sooner or later there's a cool breeze
coming in should i write that down and
the show has even been credited with
helping configure the city shattered
image andrei's big lucci from the miami
herald wrote that the show not only
helped save south beach broadcasting the
architectural charms of its long
neglected deco hotels and apartment
houses to millions around the globe at a
time when city fathers wanted nothing
more than to tear it all down for condos
miami vice practically invented the idea
of south beach
here is the host of jeopardy alex trebek
thank you very much ladies and gentlemen
on behalf of all of us welcome to
america's favorite answer in question
game jeopardy you know how we play it we
provide the categories and the answers
and it's then up to our contestants to
give us the right questions players as
you know anytime you recognize an answer
you're free to ring in however i do want
to caution you about the jeopardy if you
were wrong the value of the answer will
be deducted from your score but to help
you add to your winnings we have hidden
somewhere on the board a daily double if
you're lucky enough to uncover that then
you'll have a chance to double any or
all of your winnings up to that point in
the round and it's very important that
you try to win as much money as possible
because only the player with the most
cash at the end of the day will wind up
keeping his or her winnings if you're
all set to begin pick up your signaling
buttons but do not ring in until the
answer is fully exposed if you're ready
then let us play jeopardy
jeopardy aired on september 10 1984 and
has been on the air ever since
the late game show host alex trebek
hosted over 8 000 episodes over the
course of almost 37 seasons and has been
recognized by the guinness book of world
records for most game show episodes
hosted by the same person how about this
this one brought down the house when we
played it first
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
arguably one of the most critically
acclaimed films to come out in 1984 was
amadeus the film follows the life
success and troubles of wolfgang amadeus
mozart as told by antonio salieri the
composer who is insanely jealous of
mozart's talent and claimed to have
murdered him
the certified fresh film won four golden
globe awards four bapto awards and eight
academy awards including best picture
the film is certified fresh with a 93 on
the tomato meter critics say a lavish
entertaining powerful film about the
life and influence both positive and
negative of one of western culture's
greatest artists
this was no composition by a performing
monkey
this was a music i'd never heard
[Music]
filled with such longing
such unfulfillable longing
it seemed to me that i was hearing a
voice of god
excuse me
but why
why would god choose an obscene child to
be his instrument
hey look mr roger you got to admit this
neighborhood is falling apart
i mean look at samantha
when she starts coming home with black
eyes i think it's time for me to get out
hey that's because there were three of
those guys dad
and anyway i got one guy sneezing out of
his ear
how are you gonna support yourself huh
oh hey miss louisiana i got a great job
at a great place
it's all green with picket fences but
you always said you love new york yeah
but i love my daughter a lot more
even though take care of yourself okay
you do tony
who's the boss was a popular and
progressive family sitcom in its
depiction of a modern family in the 80s
with the reversal of gender roles and
stereotypes
the show starred tony danza as a retired
major league baseball player who
relocates to fairfield connecticut to
work as a live-in housekeeper for a
divorced advertising exec played by
judith light
morning may i help you well if you're
angela bauer i'm here to help you i beg
your pardon i'm tony miceli i'm here
about the job oh
sorry there must be a mistake this job
is for a housekeeper that's me mr good
mop well uh my mother's screening
everyone did you meet her yeah yeah
yesterday yeah you know she gave me the
once-over kicked me the tires put me up
on a rack hell she should have checked
under your hood cause you're the wrong
sex oh
wait a minute she said that wouldn't be
any problem the show also starred alyssa
milano
[Music]
that's sam in that dress
isn't she gorgeous
don't you like it dad
you look so grown up the show went on
for eight seasons on abc and averaged 33
million viewers per episode the show was
also recognized with 10 emmy nominations
and five golden globe awards tony danza
and alyssa milano are also on board to
reprise their roles as the iconic father
and daughter duo tony and samantha
macelli the show will take place 30
years after the events of the original
series
you're saying that whoever tried to kill
you is one of your guests murder she
wrote was one of the most successful
weekly series of its time the show
followed a feisty widow who solves
murders when she's not writing about
them in her hometown of cabot cove maine
a fictional coastal community with an
unusually high homicide rate during its
impressive 12 seasons the hit cbs show
won six golden globe awards and was
nominated for 41 emmy awards critics say
murder she wrote strikes the tightrope
balance of wholesome murder mysteries
with a marvelous angela lansbury proving
to be the perfect foil for tasteful
investigations into heinous crimes
[Music]
it's very important to live
this isn't true
how could that man just get up after you
not a man
machine
terminator the terminator landed in
theaters on october 26 1984. the film
launched arnold schwarzenegger into
super stardom helped to cement james
cameron's film career and even
kickstarted a multi-billion dollar
franchise which now has spawned six
films a tv series and video game
spin-offs the certified fresh film has a
100 on the tomato meter critics say with
its impressive action sequences taught
economic direction and relentlessly fast
pace it's clear why the terminator
continues to be an influence on sci-fi
and action flicks
[Music]
horror history was made in november with
the release of wes craven's nightmare on
elm street the slasher film follows
teenager nancy thompson who along with
her friends becomes the target of a kid
killer named freddy krueger a disfigured
former school janitor who's killing the
teens from within their dreams wes
craven whose earlier films include the
last house on the left and the hills
have eyes wrote and directed the film
which has arguably become one of the
most influential horror films of all
time
robert england who played freddy krueger
went on to play the iconic villain for
nearly 20 years and eight movies and a
tv show this series was eventually
rebooted in 2010 with jackie earl haley
taking over as freddy krueger this is
just a dream he isn't real
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
nervous some people huh
can i help you yes you have a
reservation for an axel foley well let's
see
i'm sorry i don't see anything out of
that name oh
check rolling stone magazine's axel
foley that's what it is
no no rolling stone no axel foley i'm
sorry sir oh it's all right you guys
probably just made some kind of mistake
with reservations why don't you just
give me another room now go up and go to
sleep i'm sorry sir but there are no
rooms available
don't you think i realize what's going
on here miss who do you think i am huh
don't you think i know that if i was
some hot shot from out of town that
pulled inside here and you guys made a
reservation mistake i'd be the first one
to get a room and i'd be upstairs
relaxing right now but i'm not some hot
shot from out of town i'm a small
reporter from rolling stone magazine
that's in town to do an exclusive
interview with michael jackson is gonna
be picked up by every major magazine in
the country i was gonna call the article
michael jackson is sitting on top of the
world but now i think he might as well
just call it michael jackson can sit on
top of the world just as long as he
doesn't sit in the beverly palm hotel
because there's no loudness excuse me
sir it seems that we do have a
last-minute cancellation uh
there is a room available it's a suite
but uh i'll only charge you the single
room rate the buddy cop movie was the
highest grossing film of the year
earning more than 316 million dollars at
the worldwide box office the film was so
popular it also won a people's choice
awards for favorite motion picture and
was nominated for best screenplay at the
oscars the certified fresh film has an
83 on the tomato meter and even landed
on afi's 100 funniest american movies of
all time
critics say the buddy cop movie
continues its evolution unabated with
this eddie murphy vehicle that's fast
furious and funny
[Music]
morning officers are y'all the second
team
we're the first team
yeah we're not gonna fall for a banana
in the tail pipe
you're not gonna fall for the banana in
the tailpipe
it should be more natural brother should
flow out like this look man i ain't
falling for no banana in my tailpipe see
that's my natural fries you've been
hanging out with this dude too long
and while we only had time to get
through a handful of film and tv shows
that made 1984 so unforgettable we need
to give some honorable mentions to some
other classics from the year like break
into electric boogaloo police academy
indiana jones and the temple of doom and
revenge of the nerds plus several other
noteworthy shows like robin hood and
night court also debuted in 1984 so from
the terminator to best picture winner
amadeus and gremlins to ghostbusters
here are the top movies of 1984 ranked
by the tomato meter
thanks for watching
you